how's Goomer is pure if you're on the
internet and you want to find out
something we all pretty much go to
Google so I'm going to do inspired by my
girlfriend Google myself so I'm going to
type is PewDiePie and then we get a
bunch of options and I'm going to answer
them this video was brought to you by
being being is the best
who the [ __ ] uses Bing first question is
PewDiePie a atheist no yes no yes no I'm
agnostic atheist basically means I don't
believe in a god but I can't disprove of
one either let's move on before the
comment section gets too much it's
already held down there is it is
PewDiePie about god damnit these [ __ ]
questions man you already know I'm not
religious yeah anyway it's PewDiePie
rich so it's not really a secret that
youtubers make a lot of money there's
been a lot of articles about me and how
much money I make kind of saddens me a
little bit cuz that's only what's
important you know I've been getting
high numbers on YouTube for a while and
now a lot of people seem to pay
attention to that but as soon as it
translates into money and all the sudden
everyone wants to know like it's it's
stupid and none of these articles by the
way with it maybe a few exceptions wrote
about the fact that we raised 1 million
dollars for charity Zoli oh it's only
interesting how much I make no not
anything else not anything good it seems
to me that the entire world cares more
about how much money I make then myself
it's pretty pie autistic I get that it's
a joke that calling people autistic on
an Internet it seems to me that half the
people who says that [ __ ] doesn't even
know what it is but yeah no no I'm not I
don't
this is like all these [ __ ] questions
do I really have to answer them
it's pretty pie dead so the reason why a
lot of people ask this is because people
like to spread around rumors that
celebrities die and then of course the
first thing you do is google is
pewdiepie dead and that's why it's a
popular search word I would assume and
no I don't hi who knows these days he's
pretty famous yeah
Wow I'm so glad I decided to do this
this has been very great so far but no
I'm not much yeah hey I get it I am a
sad loser but I'm not a sad loser that
would dress up and pretend to be his own
girlfriend but thank you very flattering
I I do appreciate you thinking that what
if PewDiePie died and my name would make
sense I guess what if PewDiePie was a
girl well I would be fabulous and you
know it baby
all right let's move on to can can't
improve I draw I think I'm alright can't
prove I speak German yes can pretty pie
play guitar
[Music]
sike there's no guitar there can poop I
sing a foxy no Kanpur if I speak Italian
well I stayed in Italy for a couple
months so I can understand bits and
pieces but now I can speak Italian
what is PewDiePie's real name fiddles i
rid of shell by i rid of is this my
middle names felix means happy
Arvid means forest and then earth means
wolf so I'm a happy wolf in a forest
what is PewDiePie's address I'm gonna
answer that with a question why the [ __ ]
do you need my address I don't know why
but my lightning broke so thank you for
watching this video I hope you learned
more about me bros because i answer some
really awkward questions just want to
stop by saying thank you for being a bro
if you didn't exist I wouldn't be able
to be here and make these videos it's my
dream to do this I love doing this
that's why I do it every day and it's
your bros support that really matters to
me so to make this extra awkward I'm
gonna brofist to you bro love you stay
awesome
[Music]